ça se passe dans un village
c'est une vieille dame très âgée c'est
la doyenne du village qui vit avec son
petit-fils qui est muet
mais un jour elle tombe malade là les
gens du village ils viennent la voir
sauf que c'est le muet qui ouvre la
porte et elle lui a dit quand il y a
quelqu'un tu me dis qui c'est donc ça
attaque à la porte il va il ouvre la
porte c'est le mécanicien qui arrive
il va la voir
comment ça va ça fait longtemps vous
m'avez vous m'avez connu j'étais tout
petit ça me fait de la peine de vous
voir malade il s'en va une demi-heure
après il y a le plombier qui arrive et
toc il va avoir le public
on va voir
une heure après il y a le maire du
village qui arrive et toc il ouvre que
c'est le maire un grand méridien c'est
qui
[Applaudissements]